hello everyone it's seven o'clock this
is Sky News breakfast the school's
Watchdog says inspections in England
will continue despite mounting pressure
for them to be paused after a head
teacher took her own life we'll bring
you reaction from the National
Association of head teachers and from
one of Ruth Perry's former colleagues
also this morning special coverage of
the deepening humanitarian crisis in
Yemen from our special correspondent
Alex Crawford it's Friday the 24th of
March
ofsted rejects calls for school
inspections to stop after a head teacher
took her own life insisting it would not
be in children's best interests
Sky news reports from a city divided by
war after more than eight years of
conflict in Yemen
dozens of families are living in this
area they've had to put up sheets to try
and obscure the view of the sniper who
has positioned himself just beyond there
Bordeaux City Hall set aligned as a
million people take to the streets of
France in protest against pension
reforms
a growing crisis exclusive figures
reveal the sharp rise in homelessness in
rural England
managed to find a ten for five we used
the last bit of money I had
history in Naples Harry Kane becomes
England's record goalscorer in a 2-1 win
over Italy
Barefoot tours for the first time
visitors to Westminster Abbey will soon
be allowed to stand on the exact spot
where King Charles will be crowned but
only if they take their shoes off
state
[Music]
hello very good morning to you the head
of the school's Watchdog says that
inspections in England will continue
amid cause for them to be paused after
the death of a head teacher Ruth Perry
took her own life in January while
waiting for a report from the school's
Watchdog which downgraded her school to
the lowest possible rating
Amanda Spielman ofsted's Chief Inspector
says that stopping or preventing School
inspections would not be in the best
interests of children
well our correspondent Melina
vesselinovich is with us as this morning
so ofsted not backing down on school
inspections despite a certain amount of
pressure on them to do so indeed they
say that the point of inspections is to
raise standards for the children and
ultimately provide a great education for
them which is what we all want she did
say that she was open to debate around
the grading of ofsted reports which some
have accused of being a little bit low
on the new ones there are four grades
and they capture a snapshot of a school
at a time but she said that ultimately
the inspections should continue she did
say that she was incredibly sorry about
Ruth Perry's death and she said that her
death was a tragedy now she expanded
more of her thoughts in a statement that
she published today I'm going to read
you a little bit from that statement in
it she writes I don't believe that
stopping or preventing inspections would
be in the children's best interests our
aim is to raise standards so that all
children can get a great education it is
an team we share with every teacher in
every School inspection plays an
important part among other things it
looks at what children are being taught
assesses how well behavior is being
taught and managed and checks that
teachers know what to do if children are
being abused or harmed goes on to say
it's important for that work to continue
and certainly all teachers want children
to be safe and they all want them to
have a great education but they don't
all agree that ofsted is the right way
to go about it they say the fact that
officer discontinuing inspections is a
grave error of judgment in the wake of
Ms Perry's death and they say that while
they want some form of an inspection
probably enough said inspection they
feel is not the right way to go about it
take a listen to what needs we need from
the National Education Union had to say
I don't think we can hear it from from
them right now but we are going to get
plenty of reaction from unions later in
the morning aren't we but um but but but
obviously there is concern amongst
teachers about the pressures that these
students yes at the moment they say that
there should be a more humane way to go
about these inspections that doesn't put
quite as much pressure on the school
leaders the accused ofsted or not having
any compassion for the burnout and the
pressure they're under on the other hand
ofsted says well inspections are really
useful tool for parents to have a
distilled view of how the school is
doing but also for the government to
know how a school is doing so they know
when they need to step in okay Elena
thanks very much indeed
uh with us breaking news to bring you
now in the last few minutes the office
support National statistics has
published retail sales figures for
February and they show that retail sales
volumes increase by 1.2 percent in
February uh 2023 this year uh following
a rise of 0.9 in January this year so
retail sales increased by 1.2 percent in
February following that rise of 0.9 in
January and the increase over the month
returns retail to its pre-covered 19
levels and these figures of course come
a day after the bank of England raised
the interest rate by a quarter point to
4.25 and it's the 11th straight increase
and it's in response to higher than
expected inflation inflation jumped to
10.4 percent in the year to February
driven by a rising cost of alcoholic
drinks in pubs as well as food
now Yemen has been gripped by war for
more than eight years it's been called
the largest humanitarian crisis in the
world by the United Nations what Sky
News has granted been granted special
access into the country after the two
countries fueling the conflict Iran and
Saudi Arabia agreed to renew diplomatic
ties well Skies the special
correspondent Alex Crawford and her team
are the first International journalists
in the country since a Saudi Iran
agreement re-established those
diplomatic ties between the two states
and she joins me now from Aiden in Yemen
so Alex first team in there what have
you made of it what have you seen
there
well we've seen an awful lot to be
honest this is a fantastic opportunity
for peace probably the closest that the
country has got to in eight years of war
and that is incredible but to be honest
I prefer to have been reporting a lot
more from here it is fantastically
difficult to get inside because you have
to get permission not just from the
internationally recognized government
but also from a myriad of armed groups
just to be able to move around the
country with multiple checkpoints
crisscrossing all across Yemen so it's
fantastically difficult not just for
outside journalists to get access but
also for people to conduct their daily
lives inside this war-torn country how
important is it it's fantastically
important that somehow Yemen is sorted
out and there is a peaceful solution
because it has triggered the world's
worst humanitarian crisis there are
literally millions of people who have
been displaced and who are basically
hungry we've been to the besieged city
of town our first report from there
showing just what life is like on the
front line here
we're given a two vehicle government
Army escort to head towards the besiege
city of Taz
it's been split in two for most of the
past eight years of war with most key
roads into and out blocked off by
fighting
it's meant a uniquely slow torture for
the Tas civilians with the houthi
militia held to one half of the City by
government troops who control the other
the city has been blasted to bits with
booby trap bombs mines and unexploded
Ordnance left scattered all over the
place by the fighters
The Siege has brought parts of Taz to
the brink of starvation yet families are
still living here
Muhammad shows us around the bombed out
shopping center which is now his home
his family is living in the basement
a lot of damage to every floor that
we've visited so far a lot of hits on
just this building alone
over there is one of the houthi bases
Muhammad tells us it's by the old
presidential Palace it's from there
snipers pick off civilians or fire
Rockets
three of Muhammad's children were born
in this Siege
they all show signs of malnutrition and
spend most of their lives inside
of course I worry about the Muhammad
says this isn't a safe place I don't let
them go outside on their own in case
there are Rockets or anything
neither children nor pensioners are safe
Cabo was shot in the back by a sniper
her home's right on the front line and
she refuses to be pushed out
I refuse to leave my house she tells us
I refuse to the houthis would shout at
me crazy woman leave your house but I
will never ever leave
the wars never stopped in Taz but hopes
of Peace seem to have halted at the
gates of this city
give you an idea of how close they all
are living to the front line at the end
of that road is where the fighting is no
man's land and dozens of families are
living in this area they've had to put
up sheets
to try and obscure the view of the
sniper who has positioned himself just
beyond there
it means constant exchanges between the
war in groups
we're defending all land and our
families one tells us
we want peace another says but they
don't want it they're killing innocent
people and children and that's why we
carry weapons
those like Fatima want Justice too the
mother of nine knows more than most
about loss
they were kids not Fighters she's
talking about her children four of them
were blown up in one day three were
killed outright the fourth only a
toddler lost a leg
photos of their mutilated bodies are all
she's left of her babies
and she's praying for revenge for their
violent deaths
she's pregnant again but doesn't want
another child in this war-torn place
she can't feed those she still has
dinner for her youngest Malik is once
again just sweet tea and bread
and that's just one sorry about that and
that's just one family devastated by
this grinding War there are literally
tens of thousands of other families just
like hers this is a whole country in
grief and filled with civilians who are
demanding not just accountability but
Justice for the multiple war crimes
which are being committed on both sides
Anna
Alex thanks very much indeed
and tonight on Sky News we'll have a
special program inside Yemen the
Forgotten War that's here on Sky News at
7 30.
to France now where widespread
demonstrations against President
macron's pension reforms show a little
sign of dying down unions have called
for new Nationwide protests next week
which would coincide with King Charles's
first state visit well a million people
took to the streets of France yesterday
in the southwest protesters set fire to
bordeaux's City Hall and the king is due
to visit that City next week
although the protest started out largely
peacefully in the capital anger
descended into pockets of violence in
Paris there were Street battles between
police and masked groups leaving burning
rubbish and vandalism in their wake
nice has discovered that rural
homelessness is increasing rapidly it's
often out of sight a tent in the
countryside or a family crammed into a
hotel room and frequently it's in areas
a wash with second homes standing empty
for much of the Year Dan Whitehead
reports on what's becoming a growing
crisis
it's 5 30 a.m and the temperature barely
above freezing we're out with the rural
homeless team in Norfolk as Dawn breaks
hidden behind a crumbling old signal box
we find Connolly hello
he's 24 and has been sleeping out here
for the last three weeks managed to find
us ten for five we used the last bit of
money I had
you obviously really cold coddly yeah it
is getting really cold now
it's quite scary
Connolly's situation is not unique
exclusive analysis for Sky News by CBRE
the countryside charity has found the
number of homeless in rural England has
jumped 21 in the last four years less
funding a lack of social housing lower
wages and a high number of second homes
are just a few of the reasons
new key Cornwall 400 miles from where we
found Connolly just meters from the
beach is the Sandy Lodge hotel it's 50
plus rooms are full but there are no
tourists this hotel is completely full
of people who are on the waiting list
for housing here in Cornwall many of
them were working full-time they were
paying private rents and one decision by
their landlord has completely changed
their lives
so this is your room this is where we
live among them is Kim she her partner
and three kids have been living in one
room in this hotel for four months
there's so many second homes there's so
many airbnbs there's so many places that
could be used to house local people
especially
but there are a lot of people I think
that come down from up country with the
idea that cornwall's the best place ever
and
it's really not
Cornwall council is spending 40 000
pounds every single day putting people
in emergency accommodation the
government says it's giving councils
hundreds of millions to help but a
recent study found that money for local
authorities to tackle homelessness is 65
percent less per person in rural areas
compared to Urban
hours after we found Connolly in his
tent he's been given somewhere to sleep
I'm just so relieved I'm really grateful
you know for what they've done you know
helped me uh come here so I'm definitely
gonna sleep well and I'll take a few
days to adjust
but it's definitely better than being
outside
for Connolly it's a chance to rebuild
not everyone facing homelessness gets
this opportunity in what is a growing
crisis in rural England
Dan Whitehead Sky News
well also making the news this morning
the president of world Athletics Lord Co
has told Sky News that the
organization's decision to exclude
transgender women from female
competitions is to protect women in the
sport the ban will include male to
female trans athletes who've been
through male puberty and it could
influence other sports
North Korea has reportedly launched what
it calls an underwater nuclear attack
drone in the latest round of weapons
tests State media says the Drone
traveled underwater for nearly 60 hours
before destinating a test Warhead east
of the country well State media also
released these pictures which they claim
show four cruise missiles launches this
week
protesters are expected to gather in
London today ahead of an expected visit
by the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu the defend Israeli democracy
London group says it'll hold an all-day
demonstration outside Downing Street to
protest against Mr netanyahu's judicial
overhauls
the BBC says it will not resume filming
for the latest series of Top Gear three
months after it after a crash that left
presenter Andrew flintoff in hospital
the corporation said it would be
inappropriate to continue filming adding
that it had sincerely apologized to Mr
flintoff the times is reporting that
he's decided to quit the show following
the incident
the daughter of a man allegedly struck
in the back by Gwyneth Paltrow in an
apparent hit and run ski crash is told a
U.S court that her father is in a really
negative Place 76 year old Terry
Sanderson is suing the Hollywood star
for three hundred thousand dollars after
the incident left him with a brain
injury and a broken four broken ribs
thank you
now with King Charles's coronation just
around the corner visit us to
Westminster Abbey are going to be given
a unique opportunity to stand in the
very spot that kings and queens of old
were crowned but there is a bit of a
catch special guided tours in
celebration of Coronation will include
access to the cosmulti pavement there it
is one of Britain's greatest medieval
art Treasures but visitors will need to
be barefoot or in socks to protect the
surface the 13th century Mosaic floor
absolutely beautiful at the heart of the
Abbey's coronation theater has been the
site of the crowning of monarchs for
more than 700 years and it's also going
to be used for King Charles this may
now a last Stitch attempt to save 16
trees and over a hundred tree stumps in
Plymouth it's going to conclude at the
high court today Plymouth city council
began its late night felling of trees
last week to make way for a regeneration
program campaigners are hoping to extend
an injunction granted and they want the
council to stop the work all together
and it is the focus of today's Sky News
Daily podcast so if you want to hear
more about it you can listen if you scan
the QR code that's on your screen now
host Sally Lockwood is joined by our
people and politics correspondent Nick
Martin to explore why councils at The
Chopping down trees are facing such a
huge backlash from local residents
and you can subscribe to the Daily for
free wherever you normally get your
podcast from
now the British Medical Association has
announced another strike for Julia
doctors in an escalation of their
dispute with the government overpaying
conditions Health leaders are warning
that up to a quarter of a million
appointments and operations could be
postponed as a result so let's hear a
little bit more about it Dr Sumi money
management
Rajan did I say your name right
apologies for that from the BMA Junior
doctors committee joins me now very good
morning to you welcome so a four day
strike announced by the BMA that's 96
hours where Junior doctors will be
walking out why do you think that's
necessary so we have been communicating
with the house secretary for over six
months now our dispute began in August
last year where we where we were asking
the health cycle should meet us and
negotiate with us on the concerns that
we have unfortunately he's taken a
ballot and actually 72 hours to bring
into the table with a mandate when he
did finally meet with us this week he
didn't actually have an offer to put to
us and that's led to the breakdown in
communication and now we've had to call
for another set of strikes to bring him
back to the table to negotiate well yes
the Department of Health says that you
the BMA placed a precondition on the
talks of a 35 pay rise is that right so
the BMA haven't actually put down any
preconditions we're willing to negotiate
our doors are always open the house
secretary asked us to meet with him and
set some preconditions however in the
room produced another list of
preconditions they want us to meet
before we could go ahead with the talks
unfortunately what actually broke down
the communication was the fact that he
didn't actually come to the table with
an offer we have given him our opening
offer which is 35 based on the amount of
money that we've lost since 2008. you
want 35 but you're saying that wasn't a
precondition for talks correct it wasn't
a precondition it's an opening offer
we're willing to negotiate but he didn't
have a counter offer okay well 35 Steve
Barkley has said that that's
unreasonable and that is seven times the
rise that nurses and paramedics have
agreed to is it that Junior doctors
think that they're worth that much more
than than their colleagues in the NHS so
I believe and the BMA believes that all
workers are paid
um it should be paid what they're worth
now that means that I believe in Pay
restoration so no work is worth less
than they were before and I believe that
trade unions should be fighting for
their members the BMA is asking for 35
because we have lost 26 of our pay since
2008 it will take a 35 uplift to bring
that back to Net Zero and it's really
important that we address this concern
now because we're already 9 000 doctors
down in the UK and we're that number is
only set to increase and the workforce
crisis is only set to get worse but 35 a
lot of people watching will say that
feels like that's never going to happen
I mean you say you're open to
negotiation how far are you prepared to
negotiate so this is our opening offer
and the reason it's so high is because
we've lost so much
um this is it you have to appreciate
this is in the landscape of what's
actually happening in the NHS at the
moment start for fleeing to other
countries New Zealand Australia Canada
because it's not sustainable to be a
doctor here and they're being offered
better elsewhere now we've got a 7.2
million long waiting list that the
government need to address they can't do
this without doctors and healthcare
workers and it's imperative that they
meet with us and negotiating good faith
the waiting list will get worse though
as a result of strikes weren't they
you've called four days of strikes why
have you chosen the particular dates
that you have in April so we have chosen
four days and this is an escalation of
the three dates that we did previously
in March the reason that we've escalated
is because the government refused to
negotiate with us and this is completely
within the government's right to call
off the strikes if they offer us pay
restoration now what we want them to do
is complement the people and we're
willing to negotiate any point our doors
are open at any time to negotiate
regardless of whether strikes are on the
table or not and we want them to come
counter an offer that we've counted the
offer that we've made so that we can
actually make progress on this and come
to a solution but I'm interested to know
why you've chosen these particular dates
because they do come after a bank
holiday weekend Easter weekend a
four-day weekend where there will be
reduced Junior doctor Cover then four
days of strikes followed by another
weekend I mean this is going to cause
huge disruption to patients isn't it is
that why you've chosen those dates so
what can happen during these periods of
time is that Healthcare trusts can
provide extra Staffing to bolster on
either side of the dates to ensure that
actually patient care is being delivered
and we've demonstrated through our 72
hours strike action that actually Junior
doctors being withdrawn from care
doesn't cause safety issues there
weren't there wasn't a single derogation
request during those 72 hours which
shows that actually this is safe and we
are providing patients the care that
they need especially with emergency care
where expert clinicians consultants and
SAS doctors are stepping down and we're
very grateful for them for doing so to
provide patient care however 175
000 appointments and operations canceled
in the last strike which was three days
so that's that reassurance about safety
obviously important but it's not going
to be much comfort to those people who
risk having operations and appointments
canceled again in April of course and
I'm extremely sorry that it's come to
this I want the government to negotiate
with us the strikes don't have to go
ahead the government can come to the
table and negotiate with us in good
faith and we can prevent this from
happening and I know that there are
going to be thousands of patients
waiting at home waiting for knee
replacement waiting for essential
operations in pain and I really want to
apologize to them because it has they
have pushed us to this the government
have do you feel hopeful though that a
deal can be struck you've seen deals
negotiated by your colleagues in the NHS
does that give you hope that a deal can
be done with Junior doctors too 100 we
are willing to negotiate our doors are
open we want to come to a solution and
the sooner we do the better for everyone
okay Dr Sumi Mane Rajan thank you very
much indeed for coming in and talking to
us from the BMA thank you
do say whether still to come here on the
show I'm going to be joined by the un's
former emergency relief coordinator to
Mark lowcock to discuss the deepening
humanitarian crisis in Yemen also ahead
I'm going to be speaking to the vice
president of the National Association of
head teachers as ofsted says that
stopping School inspections wouldn't be
in the best interests of children and
then in the next hour I'm going to be
joined by the shadow Health secretary
labors West streeting so lots to come
[Music]
foreign
has sprung in the Northern Hemisphere
and that means that the cherry blossoms
are making a bit of an appearance
meanwhile the season is well and truly
underway in Tokyo the Sakura bloomed
earlier than usual this year due to the
warmer temperatures seen in the city in
the recent weeks and as covert
regulations have been relaxed over the
last year it's the first time in four
years that people have been able to
properly enjoy these really stunning
blooms there in the city
any hope of spring in the weather
forecast I'm not sure there is but let's
take a look anyway
now when you think of a zebra Crossing
you probably don't think of one
literally crossing the street but in
Seoul Ciro the zebra managed to escape
itsu and was spotted trotting through
the streets and nosing through bins in
the South Korean capital when emergency
workers tracked zero down for three
hours they had to safely tranquilize him
before taking him back to the zoo after
his day out
let's remind you of our top stories now
this morning here on breakfast and
ofsted rejects calls for school
inspections to stop after a head teacher
took her own life insisting it would not
be in children's best interests
Sky news reports from a city divided by
war after more than eight years of
conflict in Yemen
the Sky News investigation shows a big
jump in the number of people in rural
areas with nowhere to live
[Music]
now the Prime Minister Rishi sunak has
held talks with his Albanian counterpart
Eddie Rama at Downing Street and they
spoke of a shared priority to tackle
illegal migration and people Smugglers
that meeting comes after Mr Rama
criticized Britain for singling out
Albanian migrants in the UK so our
political correspondent Rob Powell joins
me now Eddie Rama um
has spoken quite critically of how the
whole issue of migration has been
characterized certainly from Albania
hasn't he so how do these talks go do
you think it sounded like the talks
between British sunak and Eddie Rama
actually were quite productive
um he said yesterday he had pretty good
dealings with Rishi sunak anyway and I
think even though yes there's been a lot
of criticism from him especially for the
Home Secretary over what she said about
um albanians coming across the channel
references to them being criminals Eddie
Rama said that it was a disgraceful
moment for UK politics and essentially
thought that this was being done for
political reasons actually when you look
at some of the figures with 12 300
people in 2022 Albanian Nationals coming
across the channel making up 28 of
Crossings clearly that there's work to
do between the two countries to try and
prevent that and what was agreed in
those talks with vicious sunac last
night was essentially to get a joint UK
Albania team to go and assess prison
capacity in Albania with a view to
returning all Albanian Nationals
currently in the UK prison system and
they want to do some work as well to try
and stop people leaving the country in
the first place so clearly it's a big
political priority here in the UK and to
try and get to that aim of stopping the
boats as Rishi sunak puts it they need
to have the Albanian government on board
and cooperating as well yeah it'd be
really interesting I'm going to chat to
him later Rob once I say um thanks very
much indeed for that yes the Albanian
prime minister will be joining me Eddie
Rama he's coming in about half past nine
this morning so do stay watching for
that
let's take a quick look now what the
papers are covering this morning the eye
reports that there'll be no major tax
cuts this year after the bank of
England's decision to raise its base
rate again
while the Daily Express focuses on the
bank of England Governors more
optimistic forecast for the UK economy
the times leads with the rise in council
tax the average bill will now top two
thousand pounds for the first time
go to the guardian taxpayers have spent
close to half a billion pounds buying
beds in England's worst Care Homes over
the past four years
and the sun celebrates as Harry Kane
becomes England's top goalscorer
I'm sure we'll be talking about that
with Jackie shortly but in the meantime
let's return to the war in Yemen the
country has been gripped by war for more
than eight years with the United Nations
calling it the largest humanitarian
crisis in the world well Sky News has
been granted special access into the
country after the two countries fueling
the conflict Iran and Saudi Arabia
agreed to renew diplomatic ties so let's
get a view on what's going on so Martin
lowcock served as the un's emergency
relief coordinator and he joins me now
very good morning to you thanks so much
for coming in and so as we were saying
our special correspondent Alex Crawford
is in Yemen um extraordinary access to a
country that many of us have not seen
anything of because it's so hard to get
in and report from there we talk about
peace potentially Beyond the Horizon
we'll talk about the prospects for that
in a moment but it's certainly not
something that that she saw when she
went in how would you reflect on the
situation there now well firstly qdos to
have Alex Crawford I know Alex has
reported a lot from Yemen over the years
but she's the first top journalist from
a global broadcaster to be in there for
a while and the story that she tells in
that piece you you've shown today
frontaz is typical of what's Happening
all over Yemen people's lives have been
totally crashed by this war is one of
the world's worst humanitarian crises
it's not got better even though the
violence has come down a bit and the
main reason for that is that there's
been no chance to recover or rebuild
eighty percent of the population are
reliant on Aid agencies the UN the Red
Cross ngos for food and the amount of
money that's been raised for that as the
eyes of the world have come off this
problem has been falling two or three
years ago when I was at the UN
responsible for this we were raising
three four billion dollars a year last
month that this year's fundraising event
they only raised a billion so that needs
to change if we're not to see despite
the prospect of Peace massive additional
loss of life so what do you do about
that how do you raise the profile of
this conflict when so many people are
suffering well it is difficult because
the eyes of the world are on Ukraine
Afghanistan other places but I think
that the fact that Alex and hopefully
other people are there and Reporting
will shine a spotlight on this I think
the world still is not willing to
tolerate Mass loss of life running into
the millions which is avoidable and a
bit more money in Yemen this year while
negotiations go on could help keep the
situation calmer and save a lot of lives
well yes and give us a sense of the
scale of Aid that's needed the Gap I
think the Norwegian Refugee Council says
that only a quarter of the billions that
are needed for humanitarian Aid are
actually being promised less than five
percent provided for this year so
there's a huge gap there isn't there and
are people making commitments and then
just not delivering
so there is a huge gap and it used to be
better two or three years ago the UN two
or three years ago was feeding 10
million people a month because it was
Raising enough money to do that keeping
all those people alive now those numbers
have come right down because the money's
falling away the biggest missing money
if you like is from the Gulf countries
about three years ago Saudi Arabia and
the Emirates came to the UN and gave us
the Secretary General of the UN and Mia
check for 950 million dollars and that
enabled us to ramp up these relief
programs now I think partly because
they're frustrated with the behavior of
the yemeni parties the gulf countries
have stopped financing they haven't
provided or announced any money for the
UN this year and that needs to be
addressed diplomatically there are other
countries I'm afraid the UK is one of
them which has reduced its funding as
well so everyone needs to put their
shoulder to the wheel to keep all these
people alive until peace can be
Consolidated and then they can have some
recovery and rebuild their lives so
what's your message to the UK government
then
Andrew Mitchell actually to his credit
when he was on the back benches did a
lot to draw attention to the need to
find a political dialogue a peace
process in Yemen he traveled there he
was a big advocate for more humanitarian
Aid I hope now he's back in government
he's banging the same drum inside the
system and we talk about
um the prospects for peace the two
countries
fueling this war um Saudi Arabia and
Iran relations have thought a bit
between the two countries something of a
surprise agreement on thawing diplomatic
ties or or reestablishing diplomatic
ties how hopeful are you that that could
prove to be fruitful in some way I think
this is the most interesting development
over the last several years actually
facilitated by Chinese foreign minister
and it could generate a couple of
positive
um things firstly
um just last month the Royal Navy the
intercepted a boat coming from Iran to
provide Russian armaments actually to
the houthis the Saudis have been arming
the other side of the war if they stop
doing that that will calm things down
and will enable a truce to be
Consolidated the second thing they could
do though is use their political weight
and power both Iranians and the Saudis
to say to their yemeni proxies we've had
enough of this you need to behave in a
different way you need to get around the
negotiating table and give the 30
million people of your country all like
those children who we saw in Alex's
report who were simply being starved to
death by this war give them a chance of
a better future and our eyes are on you
and that's what we want you to do and
The Wider world is going to be expecting
you to do that as well that kind of
diplomatic pressure does create an
opportunity and there's a grim
anniversary I think this weekend I think
it's eight years since the War Began in
Earnest and how much longer do you think
this will go on Wars are easy to start
and hard to stop and this one in
particular which is fundamentally in its
Origins a civil war with multiple groups
and tribes and different political
outfits and everybody willing to put
tens hundreds of thousands of young boys
often and men to the front line in
pursuit of their
um you know their goals has had a lot of
staying power it Wars end when the
parties have had enough of the fighting
and enough of the bloodletting and when
enough pressure is brought to bear on
them so it's possible we could see
progress and everybody should really
take this opportunity and put their
shoulder to the wheel to secure that
okay so Mark lokka we really appreciate
you coming in to talk to us about the
so-called forgotten war that we won't be
forgetting because I need to stay here
on Sky News thanks very much indeed
because we do have a reminder for you
now that the special program here on Sky
News tonight from 7 30 with our special
correspondent Alex Crawford in Yemen
after eight years of war could Yemen
really be on the brink of Peace where
the first foreign journalists inside
Yemen since Iran and Saudi Arabia the
two Regional Powers who fueled this war
agreed to renew diplomatic ties and we
bring you a series of exclusive reports
from across the country you can watch
them only on Sky News
well worth watching that extraordinary
access that Alex Crawford has come has
got there in Yemen
now today we're saying a very happy
birthday to Dame Mary Berry with over 80
books she's one of the most respected
and loved cookery writers and Bakers in
the country but she's also a popular
broadcaster of course after she shared
her wisdom with aspiring Bakers on the
Great British Bake off until 2016 and uh
she now often appears on the radio she's
also a regular presenter for the Chelsea
flower show so a very happy birthday to
Mary Berry I don't actually know how old
she is but I'm not sure if I'd share it
if I did and now then let's turn our
attention to schools because ofsted has
rejected calls for inspections to stop
after a head teacher took her own life
saying it would not be in children's
best interests so let's get some
reaction to that Simon Kidwell is the
vice president of the National
Association I've had teachers and he
joins me now so Simon Kidwell a very
good morning to you offset has released
a statement this morning they said that
stopping School inspections wouldn't be
in the best interests of children what's
your responsibility about
good morning Anna I think in terms of
stopping the nht called for a halter
inspections last week because the actual
personal brief that we all felt hearing
about the news about Ruth's death sent
shock waves through the profession and I
know inspectors who felt unhappy about
uh inspecting last week so I think the
decision not to have a short-term pause
last week was kinead I'm really
disappointed they didn't just stop and
reflect and see how they can help School
leaders when they do make those
judgments which uh drop school grades
exactly are you asking for
King false or do you want inspections to
stop to stop and the whole system to be
rethilled
no we we we asked for a short-term pause
last week so we could actually just go
and reflect on the on the process but
we're looking for reform um at the
moment
um we're really concerned about
um inspections that are um the
complaints procedure for starters it's
um it's really difficult to go and
navigate around the complaints procedure
and I'm the head teacher I've been a
Heritage for 18 years I've had seven
inspections as a head teacher and I've
been really blessed actually because
those inspectors of inspected my schools
with both intelligence and Humanity but
what keeps me awake at that what my
colleagues are really worried about is
what happens if I get that inspector who
doesn't understand my score that
inspector who's having a bad day is the
complaints procedure robust enough to
actually deal with that because we've
seen tragically in the case of the Ruth
Perry that um the school has dropped
she's been labeled and adequate and it's
been it's been a real challenge for that
school community and it's been
devastating for its friends and family
well yes and Amanda Spielman of ofsted
did say that she acknowledged that
school inspections could be challenging
but said that inspectors always aim to
carry them out with sensitivity and
professionalism would you say that that
was the experience of most head teachers
that's my personal experience and that's
the experience of most of my colleagues
but when inspection doesn't work when
you feel that inspector isn't listening
to you the complaints procedure simply
doesn't work and we need to have a
better complaints procedure and ofsted
at a meeting I attended back in January
said the complaints procedure isn't
working for both schools and for ofsted
itself
um they also say today they've
acknowledged that the debate about
reforming inspections to remove grades
was a legitimate one would you welcome a
removing of these these four grades of
outstanding good requires Improvement or
inadequate
absolutely I think um being around
schools for a long time distilling the
value of the score in one word it's
almost impossible and actually we want
to go and that get a system where
parents can read a report and parents
are very intelligent they can actually
choose a school based on more than one
word and they can find out about the
strength of the school and its area to
development we don't think the single
word grades help anybody and serve any
purpose perhaps estate agents like them
when they're selling houses but apart
from that we don't think that they're
helpful at all
and and is there a way do you think that
you can balance out the the needs of
teachers with the needs of parents as
well and you can carry out a sensitive
inspections that take teachers and
children's considerations to hard but
also a fair and transparent way of
informing parents about what that school
is actually like
absolutely like I said my inspection
experience has been done with
intelligence and Humanity it's been done
alongside me so I feel that inspections
um it's been a partnership but we do
hear inspections that don't go very well
and we need to be able to challenge
those from day one to make sure that it
doesn't put additional pressure on
schools and school staff because we do
know that um in a recent survey for the
Times education commission that only
nine percent of teachers think that
inspection improves schools
do you think they improve schools
I think no I don't actually I think um
they're part of a quality assurance
process but in terms of school
Improvement in its current guys I don't
think they they improved schools I think
we are seeing with schools which go from
um outstanding to inadequate that that
has a devastating impact on the
community Sarah Vine the journalist
recently wrote about her son's school
that has gone from outstanding to an
adequate and she talked about teachers
leaving and demotivated pupils that
doesn't serve for any purpose of going
in pre-schools we want to make sure that
those inadequate judgments are turned
around very quickly if they happen or we
go and get rid of the grade completely
and start working alongside schools do
you think the offset has underestimated
the strength of feeling amongst teachers
about inspections
I think so I think the decision not to
pause inspections last week and it's
taken seven days for Amanda Spillman to
make that statement and those warm words
are welcome but I think the seven days
it's caused due to anxiety in my phone
hasn't stopped pinging with colleagues
anxious about ofsted I've had sleepless
nights because my school is due ofsted
anytime and I do worry about is the
systems in place if I get an inspector
who's having a bad day
a petition was handed to the department
for Education calling for ofsted to be
replaced would you back that
we're calling for reform um the nht
there is significant reform and by
working alongside the professionals we
did a significant piece of work back in
2018 around ofsted reform and we want to
work alongside ofsted to make sure it's
better for school leaders because
currently the the gap between
inspections it's been five and the bit
years for my school we know that in
caversham it was 13 years that is that
was ridiculous and it doesn't help
parents when we've got such large gaps
so we certainly would want to see ofsted
which is lower Stakes but um more
regular in terms of checking up on
important things like safeguarding and I
know that um the proposals from labor to
go and check safeguarding once a once a
year which sounds very sensible
okay well Simon Kidwell vice president
of the National Association have had
teachers we appreciate your thoughts
this morning thanks very much indeed